I am so excited to share a 15 minute
exclusive trailer for the movie with us
Barbauld
there's a strength to him that is
already
that was an awesome experience this
movie is definitely going to be worth
seeing in IMAX
the effects were like nothing like ever
I've ever seen in the theater before and
the sound was thundering into the
theater it was really bright blown away
oh my god we were just going through
that crazy mind trip that seemed
visually it's probably the craziest
thing I've seen in the movie what I see
in your future possibility
I got chills just watching it I'm the
super Doctor Strange fan I'm the guy who
has been waiting for this movie for 20
years
Benedict Cumberbatch like he did this
little intro before the video and then
he made this little hand motion and then
it kind of subscreen to starts getting
bigger and bigger and bigger until it
fills up like most of the screen which
is huge
I can't do this there is no other way
watching it in IMAX blew my mind it
makes you feel like you've in the film
rather than just watching it it 100%
takes you want to ride
a misleading every ever gets an IMAX
theater me again Alfred obviously when I
pay the people the conventions of
strange Atwater whole hands-free system
and joining the deposit hence and
schools Paloma that was great
screen TV if you don't write you this
movie in IMAX you are robbing yourself
disagree okay then I recommend is a
Technicolor got mine language but
there's a brilliant angry when I must
speaking Italian I'm gonna rule the
world so corn come to power mr. snipe
just as so yeah but you don't say study
because any of us to be there enjoy this
film is made for IMAX admission 18cm
recommend oh yeah but we should rename a
seer vimax
Rosie dr. strange in IMAX
you